Você já parou para pensar no Impacto que
um simples refrigerante pode ter na sua
saúde você pode pensar é gostoso é
refrescante eu tomo a versão sem açúcar
ou eu só tomo nos fins de semana parece
não ofensivo certo Afinal é apenas um
hábito comum a muitos especialmente os
jovens no entanto estudos recentes
revelaram uma verdade bem alarmante que
pode fazer você repensar essa escolha
cotidiana hoje Vamos explorar como algo
tão rotineiro Como beber um refrigerante
pode estar colocando sua saúde cardíaca
e geral em risco recentes estudos
trouxeram a luz a preocupante relação
entre o consumo de bebidas adoss e a
fibrilação atrial uma condição cardíaca
grave caracterizada por um ritmo
cardíaco anormal e acelerado
surpreendentemente não são apenas os
refrigerantes açucarados que são
culpados aqueles rotulados como diet ou
zero que prometem ser mais saudáveis
podem na verdade ser mais perigosos a
fibrilação atrial é a arritmia mais
comum na prática Clínica e ocorre quando
as câmaras superiores do seu coração os
átrios começam a descompassar em relação
às câmaras inferiores dos ventrículos
Isso é um problema sério que pode afetar
milhões de adultos no Brasil e pode
levar a complicações graves como derrame
insuficiência cardíaca do ponto de vista
Clínico essa condição é motivo de muita
preocupação Pois é causa de
tromboembolismo sistêmico sendo o
acidente vascular encefálico ave
responsável por cerca de 20% dos casos
insuficiência cardíaca em 30% dos
pacientes e morte em 20% dos casos mas o
que torna a fibrilação arterial tão
Traiçoeira é os seus sintomas que podem
ser confundidos com problemas menos
graves não é somente sentir o coração
fora do ritmo ou acelerado você também
pode sentir como se o seu coração
tivesse pulando numa batida forte mas
imagine sentir tonturas vertigens em
fadiga sintomas que você pode facilmente
atribuir a um dia longo e cansativo ao
estresse ou até mesmo uma noite mal
dormida no entanto essas podem ser
sinais de que o seu coração está lutando
para manter o ritmo normal uma análise
sistemática de estudos publicados desde
2015 mostrou que 30% dos acidentes
vasculares cerebrais foram causados pela
fibrilação
atrial por isso é uma doença
potencialmente perigosa com grande
impacto em validez mortes e gastos com
saúde à medida que envelhecemos o risco
de enfrentarmos dúbios cardíacos como a
fibrilação arterial naturalmente aumenta
fatores de estilo de vida especialmente
a dieta tem um papel importante nesse
aumento de risco um grande estudo
publicado na revista científica
circulation aritmia and
electrophysiology da American Heart
Association envolveu mais de 200.000
participantes todos livres de fi relação
arterial no início do estudo os
participantes forneceram detalhes
extensos sobre sua dieta através de
questionários alimentares e também
compartilharam dados genéticos isso
proporcionou uma base sólida para
explorar não apenas os fatores
dietéticos Mas também como a genética
pode influenciar o desenvolvimento de
condições cardíacas no entanto apenas
ter predisposição genética não garante o
desenvolvimento da condição durante
quase 10 anos de acompanhamento os
pesquisadores documentaram mais de 9.000
casos de fibrilação arterial eles
descobriram que os indivíduos que
consumiam mais de 2 l por semana de
bebidas adoss seja por açúcar ou
artificialmente com adoss Anes
apresentavam um risco significativamente
maior desenvolver a condição e olha só
aqueles que optavam por refrigerantes
com adoçantes como refrigerantes diet
oou zero enfrentavam riscos a ainda
maiores o maior risco da doença foi
observado em pessoas que tinham risco
genético e consumiam mais de 2 l de
bebidas adsad artificialmente enquanto
menor risco foi observado naqueles que
tinham um risco genético baixo e
consumiu menos de 1 l de suco puro por
semana esse é o primeiro estudo a
relatar uma associação entre adoçantes e
também bebidas adoçadas com açúcar e um
risco aumentado de fibrilação atrial
essa descoberta é particularmente
alarmante porque desafia a noção de que
bebidas diet ou zero São alternativas
seguras ou mais saudáveis aos
refrigerantes comuns açucarados pessoal
isso nos obriga a questionar estamos
realmente fazendo escolhas saudáveis ou
estamos
inadvertidamente trocando um tipo de
risco por outro deixe sua opinião nos
comentários você deve conhecer alguém
que facilmente toma mais de 2 l de
refrigerantes por semana estou certo
alguns tomam isso num dia quando você
adoça o seu café da manhã ou escolhe
aquele refrigerante zero para acompanhar
o almoço você pode estar fazendo mais do
que apenas satisfazer o seu desejo por
doce o que muitos não sabem é que o
impacto dessas escolhas vai além do
paladar atingindo profundamente a saúde
do nosso sistema digestório que é a base
da nossa saúde e imunidade em um estudo
revelador publicado na revista molecules
descobriu-se que o adoçantes artificiais
como aspartame sucralose sacarina e
acesulfame e potássio k tem efeitos
preocupantes sobre nossas bactérias
intestinais esses componentes não só
alimentam as bactérias nocivas mas
também causam danos diretos ao DNA de
nossas bactérias boas e vitais
interferindo em sua capacidade de
crescer e se reproduzir para se para se
nos proteger imagine o seguinte enquanto
você desfruta de uma bebida vi adossada
artificialmente sem calorias E
aparentemente inofensiva dentro do seu
corpo uma batalha silenciosa está
ocorrendo os adoçantes estão
literalmente estressando envenenando as
bactérias benéficas no seu intestino a
sacarina por exemplo mostrou-se
extremamente danosa causando o tipo de
dano celular que pode levar a mutações
genéticas enquanto o aspartame e o
acessulfame k também foram responsáveis
por danos ao
DNA pessoal o que acontece com nossas
bactérias intestinais afeta diretamente
a nossa saúde como um todo estudos
anteriores já haviam mostrado que a
sucralose e o aspartame podem reduzir
significativamente o número de bactérias
benéficas e até mesmo destruir aquelas
que são essenciais pro sistema de defesa
imune a crítica é muito forte aos dois
tipos excesso de açúcar e adoçantes
artificiais porque essas bebidas como
refrigerantes e sucos industrializados
são excessivamente repletas de açúcar e
o refrigerante dito zero pode conter
mais de um tipo desses adoçantes nocivos
alguns refrigerantes como um dos mais
famosos que você sabe muito bem qual eu
estou falando contém três adoçantes
diferentes em sua fórmula e todos eles
estão Associados a diversos problemas de
saúde Mas então você deve estar confuso
sobre a questão dos adoçantes ajudarem
na obesidade e também no diabetes certo
no final de 2021 a pesquisa mostrou que
mulheres que consumiam alimentos com
adoçantes artificiais sentiam mais fome
e comiam mais do que aquelas que
simplesmente bebiam uma bebida adoçada
com açúcar ao contrário das afirmações
da indústria Pesquisas mostram que
adoçantes artificiais estimulam o seu
apetite aumenta os desejos por
carboidratos e produzem uma variedade de
disfunções metabólicas que promovem o
armazenamento de gordura e o ganho de
peso Há também um crescente número de
estudos que mostraram que adoçantes
artificiais aumenta o seu risco de
obesidade e diabetes tipo do talvez em
um grau ainda maior do que o próprio
açúcar um estudo com animais apresentado
na conferência anual de biologia em San
Diego mostrou que a exposição a altos
níveis de glicose e administração de
adoante artificial levam a mecanismos
únicos de comprometimento vascular e
alterações homeostáticas que podem ser
importantes durante o início e a
Progressão de diabetes e
obesidade olha outro dado importante
frisando ainda mais a questão de risco a
saúde cardiovascular recentemente um
estudo realizado em 2024 trouxe mais
informações alarmantes sobre como as
bebidas adoss adas tanto com açúcar
quanto artificialmente estão diretamente
ligadas a um aumento significativo nos
Riscos de saúde cardiovascular e mental
o estudo analisou mais de 13.000 eventos
de doença cardiovascular comparando
pessoas que nunca ou raramente consomem
bebidas adoss com aquelas que as
consomem de forma regular em dois ou
mais copos por dia os resultados foram
claros e preocupantes o consumo de
bebidas adoss adas foi associado a um
risco aumentado de doenças
cardiovasculares
independentemente dos níveis de
atividade física dos indivíduos isso
sugere que os perigos dessas bebidas
podem ultrapassar os benefícios de um
estilo de vida ativo destacando a
importância de limitar a sua ingestão
além dos impactos no coração o estudo
também revelou conexões preocupantes
entre o consumo dessas bebidas e a saúde
mental beber quatro porções de
refrigerantes por dia foi associado a um
aumento de 30% no risco de depressão
comparado aqueles que não com bebidas
adoss aqueles que optam por
refrigerantes di ou zero enfrentam um
risco ainda maior com aumento de 31% na
probabilidade de desenvolver
depressão mesmo as bebidas de frutas
diet mostraram um risco alarmante de 51%
de aumento enquanto as versões regulares
dessas bebidas sucos de frutas comuns
também mostraram um aumento embora muito
mais Modesto de 88% falando
especificamente do ASP um estudo com
animais conduzido em 2022 pesquisadores
Descobriram que dos de aspartam
equivalentes apenas 85% do limite diário
recomendado pelos órgãos oficiais
provocaram não apenas comportamentos de
ansiedade mas também mudanças
significativas na expressão genética
dentro do nosso cérebro especificamente
em áreas que regulam ansiedade e o medo
essas alterações ocorreram não apenas
nos animais diretamente expostos mas
também foram observadas em até duas
gerações subsequentes esses resultados
são particularmente preocupantes porque
o aspartame não está apenas em produtos
dietéticos óbvios como refrigerante zero
ele permeia uma vasta gama de alimentos
processados disponíveis no mercado a
relevância dessas descobertas é
amplificada por uma declaração recente
de 2023 da Agência Internacional de
pesquisa sobre câncer da Organização
Mundial de Saúde classificando o
aspartame como um possível carcinógeno
ou seja como sendo um produto que pode
causar câncer pessoal o que isso
significa para nós consumidores estamos
potencialmente consumindo um produto que
pode afetar de forma profunda nosso
bem-estar emocional e físico
influenciando não apenas nossa própria
saúde mas Possivelmente a de futuras
gerações compartilhe os vídeos faço bem
a vida de alguém pode mudar também no
canal do Alé
dovv Muito obrigado pela sua atenção não
esquece dividir esse vídeo com seus
amigos e familiares um grande abraço um
beijo no seu coração e você é fera